hi I'm Evan Carmichael from Emma comical
calm and also a frequent contributor to
the Telus talks business blogs here's
the blog and one of my recent posts over
the past few months I've been answering
questions from our readers and they've
been asking on and we've been creating
videos that we've been putting up on our
YouTube channels and we have one more
question and answer day left in the year
so it's coming up on December twentieth
and what I want to encourage you guys to
do is write in with your questions so
you can either post it underneath this
video you can ask them via email via
Twitter on youtube or on Facebook I want
to create one more video for the year
answering your questions are going to
try to answer as many as I can for you
guys so if you have any questions about
finishing up the year or heading into
the next year on a high I love helping
entrepreneurs I want to be able to see
you guys make 2013 the best year yet and
so feel free to leave a question under
this video on our Facebook page email me
personally or give me a tweet and I'm
going to do one video it's going to come
out in December twentieth to answer all
of them together hopefully a lot of
value add in that one video so I'm
really looking forward to it if you guys
have been liking the videos in the past
feel free to give it a thumbs up below
and makes us want to do more of these
videos for you and again please leave a
comment either under the video or send
it in to us so that for that final video
coming out this year December twentieth
you're going to get your question
answered and also hopefully learn a lot
more from everybody else's questions as
well thank you and we'll see you soon
you